and john means will try to
slow down this juggernaut 13 straight
wins
with good offense and really whatever
they need that they get
you know they've had four shutouts and
they do it all wilson sitting on a
nine-game hitting streak
and he got him 80 mile an hour off speed
means gets him one two three yeah like
you know 94
and then when you need to get him out we
talked about the breaking ball there it
was
and they're gonna be staring down jesus
lizardo aka
zeus for the oakland ace he's making his
fifth turn of the season as well been a
little bit of a rough sledding
early on for lizardo but flashes of him
turning the corner in his last outing
against minnesota
one and two the count to michael franco
swaying gonna miss 98 mile an hour
fastball and that will do it for the
orioles in the bottom of the first no
score after one
from baltimore matt chapman three homers
11 rbis and leads the american league
and strikeouts with 28.
another pop-up left side of the infield
franco wind taking it blowing it in and
he can't hang on
you can see he was having trouble had a
long way to go that wind pushing it back
toward home plate
one two and he adds to his lead leading
strikeout total
well perfect pitch outside corner 94
riding fastball
great angle here balls already by him so
two down and that sends up
steven piscotti one-two pitch
a little flare and that'll work
so piscotti has a two-out hit first hit
for the a's
a ball two strikes two down no score
we're in the oakland second inning
and he throws it by him for strike three
second strikeout for john means
well again the good pitchers can add and
subtract here's a little extra at
95 miles per hour castle 304
with a double and home run against
left-hand pitching this year
weather's going to start to get nice
rosario gets his second strikeout so may
would be a good month to come on out
well we're seeing a really good fastball
from jesus lizardo here in the early go
austin hayes 222 on the season no homers
a couple of rbis that's hid well
way back in left center field and that
is out of here
austin hayes the long ball that's been
missing in the oriole attack
and the birds go up one nothing launched
rocket see you later 35 innings since
the orioles have done that
good high ball hitter gets one to hit
and doesn't miss it ira miss garcia the
catcher
to lead off for oakland here in the
third inning
down he goes good change up great change
up
you can see great late fade means he's
able to stay behind it and just turn it
over a little bit get it to run away
from the right-handed hitters
mark can a 23 run scored on the season
stops in the major leagues
bounce to third franco got one at second
on to first the orioles turned two
nice double play to end the inning birds
on top one nothing turn it
two strikes to ramone aureus
good pitch fastball right on the inside
corner marias gets caught looking
lizardo going to dial up 96 on the black
inside
here's lauriano one of the early signs
of a guy starting to figure things out
is not shying away from contact that
one's hit well
left center field and that baby's gone
into the orioles bullpen and we're tied
at one
so number three for l'oreal is a 110
mile an hour
rocket off the bat of the laser how
about that couple lefties
fastballs deposited into souvenir city
and in steps austin hayes
that's it well deep to right center
field
way back and out of here austin hayes
second homer of the day gives the
orioles a 3-1
lead and another big blast 104.9 off the
bat
on that one and that's austin hayes
second career
multi-homer game
that looks like a swing and it is and
that is how the
bottom of the fourth comes to an end
galvez not sure about it but we
are we're also sure that hayes hit a
two-run homer
there you go pull the string strike him
out
but it took him what six seven pitches
to do
and and that that's what they want pitch
count now at 70.
and there's a change up see how far out
front
i mean he took a couple early on that i
thought were even
better this one is right down the middle
but he just fools him
top of the order cedric mullins
and he's three for three in this game
base hit to right field
yeah you got to make the perfect pitch
and then to me
it all comes with number confidence
franco strikeout to fly ball to center
field today
three for nine in the series and
swinging a miss 98 miles an hour so
lozaro pumped up
as the orioles strand a pair in the
bottom of the fifth we are headed to the
sixth
three one baltimore clario for two
and he got him at 84. down goes lowry
out number one well we told you he
throws about 29 percent
change-ups but right here of course
lowry doesn't know
and it's a perfect change-up olson over
two
bounce to short and it'll fly ball to
cedric mullins
[Applause]
popped up right side mancini has room
and trey makes the catch to end the
inning so down go the a's one two three
in the six john means taking care of
business
3-1 orioles 0-2 to pedro severino who's
the cleanup hitter for
the orioles and he got him swinging
sixth strikeout for lizardo
did he go yes he did says manny gonzalez
so hayes can't believe it a couple of
strikeouts for lozada we are moving to
that's paul fry's turn
fair ball down to third franco up with
it fires across got him
what a nice play you know kind of
hugging the line because of the slider
which was the ball that got hit so hard
down there and then
able to love it because of positioning
and and then over to ryan mount castle
big target over first franco
has gone hitless in this game today
that's it well way back in left center
and michael franco's got a home run his
second as an oriole bird's third of the
day and there's a little more breathing
room
as the orioles go up 4-1 pitch number
ten
three and two to mckenna guerra comes
home
ball four he did win it so gibbon rbi
four walks in the innings for guerra
so cedric mullett's top of the order
left on left here
bounce to short there's another run
well it's been a long inning and it's a
play that he usually makes but the
the one thing that cedric mullins does
as well as anybody is the speed factor
mancini has got an opportunity they're
still loaded birds have batted around
and there's a base hit that should get
two more in
two rbis for trey mancini and the
orioles really opening up some breathing
room here
so you now have eight reasons why
there's 13
game winning streaks going to end zach
lother
major league debut trying to close off
that 13-game win streak
strike three there's his first major
league k
ends the game the orioles win
and oakland's 13-game win streak comes
to an end